cable should have his own movie series
he can exist independent of Deadpool in
a heartbeat she has for years if dad
pulls me in like 330 comics on cables
minute about 520 yes I've counted but he
had x-force and his own cable series and
then cable Deadpool him in his own cable
series and then another x-force in his
own cable series you know the bottom
line is especially you know I in between
Deadpool to being rapping and then
opening I got really close with Josh and
he was very excited about exploring
cable and the subsequent sequels the X
for standalone movie that was in his own
words cable centric and and I just you
know I just hope that eventually when
Marvel turns the lights back on again
and goes into full operation mode that
they can realize that like look Kevin
you're great you're brilliant but part
of being brilliant is um you know
letting lieutenants go off and make some
of that brilliant stuff in and I don't
know how much we can oversee on a
day-to-day I literally don't I don't
maybe if Kevin Feige a singer he's like
hey [ __ ] I can oversee 25 okay I can
oversee 25 projects in a timeline belt
so backup but in my mind I'm like why
not you know um delegate maybe a cable
movie to somebody else and just
overseeing it because as wonderful as
Kevin is there are clearly other paths
to those successes
whether it's patty Jenkins whether it's
Lord Miller whether it's Ryan's version
um the vision being enacted you know
there may not be other debt - I'm fine
because I have to live with the fact
that I had two amazing experiences -
movies I'm extremely proud of I love
knowing everybody on those movies I love
Ryan Josh tzatzi David Tim Miller all of
them um that the work they did was
fantabulous those movies
test of time you know but in the world
we live in nothing is guaranteed and it
takes a lot to make movies and in post
quarantine it's weird what I what I
don't really understand is given the
audience why there isn't a Deadpool
cartoon yeah like I don't understand
that um right losing the Donald Glover
like just the script he released from
his like I'm leaving this project those
eight pages was some of the most
inspired voice I've ever encountered
and it was like we lost something it was
the I think the biggest loss in pop
culture of my generation I can tell you
stories chord oh I got it no I can tell
you buddy buddy whoo that was a gut
punch but that's like two and half years
ago I'm still not over it no just
kidding